[Music]
see no hugs and kisses in Halle Berry's
new movie kidnapped but what you get is
95 minutes of non-stop scream at the
screen action as how his character lives
through every parent's worst nightmare
but here's the question did the mama
bear nearly have her own real life scare
have you ever had that bonus in a store
I was busy looking at a tag Nala was
very little she was there I looked
around and she was not there and you
have that moment where I was like I went
right into nobody's leaving this piece
until I find out where my daughter is
and it's just what happens it's visceral
luckily she was like a foot away from me
under the turnstile but for in that
moment she was gone that real-life scare
is taken to the extreme and kidnap her
co-star nine year old sage Korea is the
same age as Halley's daughter Nala and
yes there were some playdates did you
two get to hang out yes I had like small
like squeeze trailer and then I go over
there to see Nala and her trailers big
there's a bedroom be telling all my
business pallies other co-star is the
minivan that helps her chase down her
son's abductors do you or would you
drive a minivan because clearly that's
the best car I mean I have one I do too
don't you love it I love vacuum cleaner
people don't understand how great or
many ways oh it's the perfect family car
and I don't care what anybody says I'm
proud of it yeah sanitation he proof
here's Hallie with for real minivan my
god I love him honey van
you
you